everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm and today we're in round 4
of our coverage of the 2017 US chess
championships our competitors today
white is played by Wesley so currently
tied for first with a few players with
two points after three rounds one of
those players he is tied with he's
facing today with a black piece and that
is Alex honest kook and both of these
guys beat the same player Wesley so beat
shovel up in round one and Alex beat him
in round two besides that they have two
draws so coming into this round both
players film pretty confident we'll go
ahead and get started with Wesley so
with the white pieces Knight to f3 pawn
down here d5 pawn g3 getting ready to
castle on the kingside and being kind of
as bishop here to g2 Knight f6 Bishop g2
Pawnee six Castle on the kingside Bishop
e7 upon c4 and usually when you see this
it's kind of a delayed Queens gambit so
after the king castles over here it's
almost guaranteed that we're going to
see pawn to d4 most players are not
playing the English opening as much if
they are playing the English opening
maybe they transition into something
around Knight to c3 and try to go that
route but usually it's just the Queens
gambit declined line and so that's
almost what it looks like Alex was
preparing for with the pawn here to e6
pawn to d5 Wesley so decided we're going
to change things up a little bit and
we're going to definitely be playing the
English opening no Queens gambit today
and we're going to play pawn to be three
so pretty irregular opening variation
specifically in the English opening and
it took black by surprise he wasn't
really sure how he would respond to this
he ended up playing pawn to b6 I think
it would have been a little sharper if
he'd have played pawn to d4 he does have
protection from his queen this limits
some of the moves that white can play he
can't be bringing his knight here to c3
he can't push forward with pawn to d4
which you would at some point like to do
kind of ties down his knight here on F
3/2
spawn later on if he wants you could
push forward to pawn to c5 really
solidify that you know we could see
continued Bishop to b2 because that's
one of the main reasons that we see pawn
to b3 pawn c5 solidified once kind of
break this up
that's fine Knight cc6 we could see the
pawn capture the Pinery capture here on
d4 this is still just kind of a pain all
these pieces are going to have to deal
with this pawn before the pawn here on
d2 can really do too much so I think
this would have been fine you know even
if Queen to e2 Queen b6 adding more
pressure and the term the board PI maybe
like this a little bit more but decides
to go with the pawn here to b6 Weslaco
continues with Bishop to b2 and then
Alex plays a bishop be setting being
catering on the Queen side of the board
pawn takes on d5 Knight recaptures on d5
and then pawn up to d4 and this is where
I think Wesley so did a lot of his
preparation with upon the center of the
board he's got a nice little pawn chain
he has very active board state he is not
involved he has these semi open files
that he can get his rook over here to
like c1 really control a lot of the
board that he wants to he has bishops on
both side of the board so W ship here
but controlling a lot of the board you
can see controls more than the double
bishop pair here with this dark square
bishop not really attacking too much
with these dark squares right here both
of whites aiming at the center of the
board Knight to d7 you know I'm not sure
the 90 d7 is my favorite could have gone
completely Yolo
if you wanted to pawn to f5 looks
interesting that's kind of the if you
want to get creative with pawn to b3
we're just going to go completely off
the radar with pawn to f5 could have
also tried say c5 just break up the
center of the board if he wants to
pawned a5 if he wants to go crazy over
on the Queen side but Knight to d7 is
fine but that's really just preparing
pawn to c5 it's pretty telegraphed
knowing that there's not a lot of other
great squares you want to bring your
knight over here to d7 and then bring it
to Knight to f6 to really control the
Knight to d5 d5 this is not where you
want your knight anyway
and right now I can't come here to see
five or five Rick over here to e1 just
preparing to push the pawn up and
control the center of the board pawn to
c5 as expected and then pawn to e4
kicking the knight back here to f6
Knight c3 last kind of development move
from white and then we do see in
exchange off the center of the board and
then Knight down here to e5 and this
opens up the door for the Queen to
attack and wants to make sure that he
doesn't have a cramped position because
with the night here on d7 it does kind
of limit the rooks if they want to kind
of control these open files and the
Queen can't really do too much so night
here on e5 is going to be where it sits
for a while it does also stop this pawn
right here on e4 from pushing a little
bit so this Bishop here on g2 does have
a little bit limited exposure to
controlling the rest of the board Queen
to e2 bishop down d5 getting the dark
square bishop we talked about wasn't
very active so it's a little bit more
active both of the bishops kind of
eyeing down on the King side of the
board from Wesley so rook to d1
controlling this open file Queen here to
e7 getting the Queen out of the way
getting ready to bring these rooks over
and control those open files as well
Knight to a4 attacking the bishop the
bishops kind of forced to take the
knight here on a d4 it gets a little
tricky if you were to try to be cute if
this is one kind of back to d6 that's a
little bit too passive but if you were
to try something Bishop to b4 and all of
a sudden pawn to a3 kicked it back and
now all of a sudden the knight could
take it blacks count just wasted to move
but you could instead even play Knight
to b5 preparing for Knight up here to c7
so all in all just gets pretty bad he
decides to go ahead and give up his
Bishop here takes with his Bishop here
on d4 and then the bishop recaptures
Knight comes back here to c6 attacking
the bishop and he had a few options here
I thought he might try to just take here
on f6 I don't think that Alex would
recapture with his
queen just because pawn to e5 forcing
the Queen to move now all of a sudden
rook to these sakes really getting up in
the business of black so I think instead
he might have tried with the pawn taking
from g7 so after the pawn takes which
you work over here to c1 not the best
pawn chain three pawn chains going into
the indie game I think this favors
White's but it looks like Wesley so even
though he has a slight advantage I think
with this exchange it seems like he
feels more confident with more pieces on
the board specifically double bishop
pair that he'll give up that slight
advantage in exchange to make sure that
he holds on to his material and that's
kind of where you feel like someone
who's playing at the top of their game
that's how they want to be playing they
don't want to exchange down on the board
as much as possible they want to keep as
much and just see what they can do it
because they think they can outmaneuver
their opponents
so Bishop III rook over here to d8
trying to control the center of the
board Knight here to c3 Queen down here
b4 putting pressure getting it more
involved Queen here on East 7th wasn't
doing too much Queen over here B to
protecting this nice Knight down here to
a g4 attacking the bishop just says hey
I want to go ahead and exchange this
material off the board even if you don't
want to Bishop here to f4 does not want
to exchange once to get it in a very
active position right here and the
Knight to e5 and I really like this
square from Alex I think this blocks
exactly what white wants to be
controlling it has a lot of protection
from both of the Knights here this pawn
can't push forward
so this bishops not doing too much all
no I really like this position I think
both sides have a lot of good things
going for them but I would give a slight
advantage to black white continues with
pawn to a3 forcing the clean back Queen
here to c5 Knight a4 Queen here b5 we do
see a two fold repetition after Queen to
c5 and that comes back here to a four
and then after Queen to b5 again Wesley
so has the opportunity to go for
threefold repetition if he just comes
back here to Knight to c3 then we're
going to
have a drawl in the game and afterwards
they kind of asked him like hey you have
a drawl you know it's not necessarily
the best position right here if anything
I would kind of give the very slightest
of edge to black in this position it's
going to be very difficult for white I
think to find an opening here Wesley so
just said I wanted to try for a victory
maybe objectively in this position I
should have gone for the drawl but
decided to play on did not want to go
for the threefold repetition draw and
set decide to play pawn to h3 so kind of
reset and let's let's keep going from
here and then Knight to d3 is where
things started to get a little bit
interesting probably more correct is to
just take here first rook takes on d1
Knight down here to d3 we do see the
rook take so that's pretty interesting
right away rook takes back on d3
pawn takes the knight here on a g4
and after the Queen comes down takes the
pawn a bishop to f1 and we see an
exchange on board with the Queen's and
so we kind of reached the in-game state
here where black gave up you know some
of his pieces in exchange for Wesley so
look in black does have a pawn advantage
just slightly but this is very dangerous
to give Wesley so double bishop pair
going into the in-game Knights just
going to be difficult to deal with black
has to make sure that he dominates all
these files with his rooks and puts as
much pressure that he can with this
LightSquared Bishop what's the so just
needs to completely overwhelm his
opponent with all of its pieces and so
we kind of go into the in game from here
rook to a b3 attacking the knight Knight
comes up here to c4 wants to get it as
aggressive as possible rook to the 8 not
up here to d6 is being protected by this
bishop so all of a sudden has come down
here from b2 and it's starting to cut
away some of the critical squares that
black hats Bishop to a AIT's not exactly
where you want one of your aggressive
pieces back here on a a yes it is
controlling some of these diagonal
squares but you really want that Bishop
to be in the center controlling a lot of
the board
playing an open board state going into
the in-game pawn here to g5 from Wesley
so Alex plays rook to c3 pawn up here to
a4 just doesn't want to have to worry
about this one starts put a little
pressure on the Queen side as well rook
here to c5 pawn up here to e5 rook down
to d7 and this is kind of an interesting
move Bishop to e3 attacking the rook and
saying what are you going to do here
giving up this pawn and material and
what does he give up the pawn for just
so he can control this file on you know
with his rook here on c1 so we talked a
lot about having your rooks control
files because it gives them so much
reach and does exactly what they're
meant to do and control a lot of the
critical squares on the board but Wesley
so just proved I'm going to give up
material for the sole point of trying to
control that file which is always nice
to see work back here to d8 now as rooks
are kind of separated you want them to
be connected so they have some
protection you don't have to have your
other pieces your bishops or even your
pawns protecting them they can kind of
control each other
rook up to c7 any time you get your rook
to your opponent's 7th rank that's
always a good thing is you can kind of
see right here this nice on d6 is going
to also be protecting this right here
black cannot take the knight on the six
because there's just going to be
checkmate you know check where it comes
back here to d8 and then checkmate so
that's not going to be good instead
decides to play a rook to d5 trying to
add a little bit more pressure so he
could take the knight if he wants to but
then just nice to f7 it is protected
rook here to f8 just being completely
defensive but it's just not helping
because he doesn't have any of his
pieces you know really connected or
doing too much in this Bishop on a just
isn't doing anything at all pawn to g6
and says yeah I'm fine giving up that
material so you have double pawns here
and you just have three pawn chains that
are not helping each other at all and so
I'm going to play Knight to g5 this also
starts to open up the door
some really strong attacks from the
bishops one thing that gets in the way
of bishops is strong pawn chains so this
is kind of eating away at some of the
strong pawn chains that black hats which
is really the only defense from as King
right now we're down here to d1 not
really threatening too much this Bishop
it's going to have a few moves if wants
to maybe come down to d5 and then c4
which you'd still be being attacked by
this rook to even start to put pressure
does pin down the bishop but also takes
away the ability for the rook on d1 to
do anything so the nice is going to come
up here take material on e6 as thanks
Alex for that move rook to e8 work over
here g7 check and then just going to
gobble up these two pawns very very easy
for Wesley so to do and now protecting
this nice now the bishop does get
involved into the game a little bit late
to the party but after Bishop to d4 Alex
is forced to resign there's just too
much pressure going on what just shows
up a lot of material and there's no way
for him to really stop the onslaught
that's going to be going on from here so
Liddell congratulations to Wesley so
trying some really out of the box
openings see what his opponent does I
think Alex defended extremely well for
an English opening variation we don't
see very often and then kudos to Wesley
so also Ford not accepting the draw and
fighting on and you know getting his
opponent to a spot where he probably
thought it was going to be a draw
film pretty good about it after four
rounds you're going to be tied at the
top you know you tie Wesley so who's
kind of the top player in this
tournament when he has the white pieces
and I think he just got a little
flustered after pawn to h3 didn't know
how to cope with that and then just made
a few mistakes it's all no exciting game
really excited to see all these rounds
have some great games not some of the
cookie cutter you know openings and
defenses we've seen in some other
tournaments this has been fireworks most
of the tournament so hopefully you guys
are enjoying and I will see you tomorrow
for round five